This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. I'm sorry. It's one of the simplest things to say, and also one of the hardest. That's especially true when we're apologizing to the most important people in our lives. When we've wronged a parent or a partner or a close friend, working up the courage to make amends can sometimes feel really hard. Why is that?
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我很抱歉。这是最简单的一句话，也是最难说出口的一句话。当我们向生命中最重要的人道歉时，尤其如此。当我们伤害了父母、伴侣或挚友时，鼓起勇气去弥补有时会感觉非常难。这是为什么呢？
Why do many of us find it difficult to apologize, especially to the people we love? This week on Hidden Brain, we conclude our Healing 2.0 series with a look at the psychology of apologies. We'll consider the mental barriers that make it hard for us to acknowledge when we've done something wrong, the changing cultural expectations around apologies, and why it may be useful to think of an apology as a gift. Think about the last time someone wronged you. Did they apologize? Now think about the last time you wronged someone else. Did you apologize?
为什么我们中的许多人觉得道歉很难，尤其是对我们爱的人？本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们以探讨道歉心理学的视角，来结束我们的“疗愈2.0”系列。我们将探讨那些让我们难以承认自己做错事的心理障碍、围绕道歉不断变化的文化期望，以及为什么把道歉看作一份礼物会很有用。想想上一次有人伤害你的时候。他们道歉了吗？再想想上一次你伤害别人时。你道歉了吗？
At the University of Queensland in Australia, Tyler Okimoto studies the psychology of apologies. He examines the transformative power of apologies, and what happens in our minds when we say, I'm sorry. Tyler Okimoto, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you Shankar, glad to be here. I want to take you back Tyler to the 2016 Rio Olympics, the star US swimmer Ryan Lockty and other athletes said that they had been robbed at night by armed men. It turned out the story was only a cover for what really happened
在澳大利亚昆士兰大学，泰勒·奥基莫托研究道歉的心理学。他审视了道歉的变革力量，以及当我们说“我很抱歉”时，我们的大脑会发生什么。泰勒·奥基莫托，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔，很高兴来到这里。泰勒，我想把你带回2016年里约奥运会，美国游泳明星瑞安·洛赫特和其他运动员称他们夜间在街头被持枪歹徒抢劫。事实证明，这个故事只是掩盖真实情况的借口
and that this is a classic example of how we often react when we're accused of doing something bad. Yeah that's right that's right first reaction is deny, come up with an excuse trying to paint yourself in the best possible picture. And it turned out what had actually happened is that he had been drinking, been partying, had thrown a tantrum in the store, had done some property damage, and the security guard had tried to intervene and stop the behavior and locked the realizing that this was going to be a PR problem for him. Invented the story, put out a statement in expectation that something negative was going
而且，这堪称一个经典案例，展示了当我们被指控做了坏事时通常会作何反应。是的，没错，没错。第一反应是否认，想出一个借口，试图把自己描绘成最好的形象。事实证明，真正发生的事情是，他在喝酒、开派对，在商店里发脾气，破坏了一些财物，保安试图介入并制止这种行为，而洛赫特意识到这将成为他的公关危机。于是他捏造了故事，发表了一份声明，预料到会有关于他的负面消息
to come out about him. It was only with hindsight and time that he was actually able to step up and own up to the fact that he'd blatantly lied. So in some ways this is the adult version of, you know, the dog ate my homework. I want to talk about one other incident which I think really reveals the power of what happens when apologies go off the rails. In April 2010, an oil rig exploded in the Gulf of Mexico, it killed 11 workers, it ignited a fireball that was visible 40 miles away. This was the infamous deep water horizon oil spill. The rig was leased by BP one of the largest oil companies in the world. Here's how BP responded according to news reports.
爆出。直到事后经过了一段时间，他才真正能够站出来，承认自己公然说谎的事实。所以在某种程度上，这就是成年版的“狗吃了我的作业”。我想谈另一个事件，我认为这真正揭示了当道歉偏离正轨时所发生事情的威力。2010年4月，墨西哥湾的一座石油钻井平台发生爆炸，造成11名工人死亡，并引发了一个在40英里外都能看到的火球。这就是声名狼藉的“深水地平线”漏油事件。该钻井平台由世界最大的石油公司之一英国石油公司（BP）租用。以下是根据新闻报道BP的反应。
Almost from the moment on April 20th that oil began filing the Gulf BP seemed to view the disaster through rose-colored glasses. May 13th Chairman Tony Hayward speaking to the Guardian newspaper. The Gulf of Mexico is a very big ocean, the volume of oil and dispersant we're putting into it is tiny in relation to the total water volume. Five days later, Hayward again, to Britain's sky news, I think the environmental impact of this disaster is likely to be very modest. The Gulf of Mexico is a very big ocean.
几乎从4月20日石油开始涌入海湾的那一刻起，BP似乎就透过玫瑰色眼镜来看待这场灾难。5月13日，董事长托尼·海沃德在接受《卫报》采访时说：“墨西哥湾是一个非常大的海洋，我们投入其中的石油和分散剂的体积与整个水体相比微不足道。”五天后，海沃德再次对英国天空新闻说：“我认为这场灾难的环境影响可能会非常轻微。墨西哥湾是一个非常大的海洋。”
Tyler, what are you here in BP's response? Well, it's a bit of a ryan locked you on the bigger scale, right? It sounds like the initial responses do seem to be about minimizing the damage. I actually remember Tony Hayward's apology quite vividly. I was living in the state at the time, and I turned to my wife after watching the commercial that BP put on television,
泰勒，你从BP的回应中听出了什么？嗯，这有点像是放大版的瑞安·洛赫特事件，对吧？听起来最初的反应似乎都是关于尽量减少损失的。我其实对托尼·海沃德的道歉记忆犹新。我当时住在那个州，在看了BP在电视上播放的广告后，我转向我妻子
where I remember seeing it live, and turning to her and saying, oh, this looks like a PR stunt. It's not going to go well. So BP initially said it was maybe 5,000 barrels a day that was flooding into the ocean, but at its peak it turns out there were tens upon tens of thousands of barrels a day flooding into the ocean. Now that's a really big difference. Again as people heard this I think they heard exactly what you just said which is that BP was trying to minimize the extent of the damage.
我记得我是看直播的，然后转过身对她说，哦，这看起来像是一场公关特技。这不会有好结果的。所以BP最初说每天可能只有5000桶原油涌入海洋，但在其峰值时，事实证明每天有数以万计桶的原油涌入海洋。这可是一个非常大的差距。同样，当人们听到这个消息时，我想他们听到的正是你刚才所说的，即BP试图淡化损害的程度。
Yeah, yeah, that's right. And while I might try to give Tony Hayward the benefit of the doubt, and that maybe he didn't have all the information, and maybe that statement was to the best of his knowledge, you know, it is a bit difficult to swallow an error of 60 fold. So if just seems like in immediate reaction, seemed to be more concerned with reassuring the company of what was happening rather than necessarily thinking about what the public actually wanted from that situation. I want to play you another clip of the next aspect of the BP Deepwater Spill saga when a reporter confronted Tony Hayward, here's what he said.
是的，是的，没错。虽然我可能会试图给托尼·海沃德一些宽容，也许他并没有掌握所有信息，也许那个声明是他所知范围内的最好结果，你知道，要吞下一个大得出60倍的错误确实有点难以下咽。因此，直接的反应似乎更关心向公司重申发生了什么，而不是去思考公众在那种情况下真正想要什么。我想放给你另一段音频，关于BP深水漏油事件传奇的下一个方面，当时一名记者当面质问托尼·海沃德，他是这么说的。
So here what says I'd like my life back. And I'm sure that was the case, I'm sure he wasn't having a good time while this was unfolding, but it does sound like he was seeing the problem through the lens of his own self-pity. Yeah, that's right. I think there was a collective grown across the entire PR world when he said that. I can understand kind of what he was trying to get across.
所以这里他说的是“我想找回我的生活”。我确信事实确实如此，我确信在事件展开时他过得并不愉快，但这确实听起来他是透过自我同情的镜头来看待这个问题的。是的，没错。我想当他说出这句话时，整个公关界都发出了一声集体叹息。我能理解他想表达的意思。
He's trying to show that he's empathizing, that I understand the pain. I'm feeling it too. But the way that he said it and the timing with which he said it really made it come off as really I'm the one suffering here. And he seemed to be more concerned with his own experience. We've seen how our initial response to our own wrongdoing is often marked by denial, minimization, and self-pity. These responses often produce an unintended consequence. They make the victims of our wrongdoing furious. Here is a Gulf Coast resident responding to Tony Hayward and BP. If you care, stop the oral from coming into our
他试图表现出他在共情，我理解这种痛苦。我也感同身受。但他说这话的方式以及他说话的时机，真的让人觉得，其实受苦的人是我。他似乎更关心的反而是他自己的经历。我们已经看到，我们对自身不当行为的最初反应往往以否认、淡化和自我同情为特征。这些反应常常产生一个意想不到的后果。它们让那些因我们的不当行为而受害的人勃然大怒。以下是一位墨西哥湾沿岸居民对托尼·海沃德和BP的回应。如果你在乎，就阻止石油流入我们的
estuaries. If you care, I don't think you do care. I think you care about your image. You don't care about us. Now it's possible that people would have been furious, regardless of what BP did. The spill went on to be one of the worst in history. Hundreds of thousands of marine animals were killed. But Tyler says that BP's response not only didn't help, but may actually have made things worse. When you feel victimized and then somebody's response to that is insufficient,
河口。如果你在乎的话——我不认为你在乎。我想你在乎的是你们的形象。你们根本不在乎我们。现在，即便BP什么都不做，人们也可能会大发雷霆，这并非不可能。这场漏油事件后来成为历史上最严重的事件之一。成千上万的海洋动物丧生。但泰勒说，BP的回应不仅无济于事，实际上可能还让情况变得更糟。当你觉得自己成了受害者，而别人的回应却很不充分时，
it can really compound the negative feeling as a consequence of that. So it feels rather than just an accident. This is an accident that nobody actually cared about, that there is no remorse. That makes it just that much worse. As Ryan Lockty discovered, there is a very high cost to not getting apologies right. Three months after the rig exploded, Tony Hayward was forced to resign as CEO. BP's public image took a beating. Coming up, saying I'm sorry is one of the first things parents teach their children. So why is it so hard for grown-ups to apologize? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
这确实会加剧由此产生的负面情绪。所以感觉这不仅仅是一场意外。这是一场根本没人关心的意外，没有任何悔意。这就让情况变得更加糟糕了。正如瑞安·洛赫特所发现的那样，没有妥善处理道歉要付出非常高昂的代价。钻井平台爆炸三个月后，托尼·海沃德被迫辞去首席执行官职务。BP的公众形象一落千丈。接下来，说“对不起”是父母教给孩子的第一批事情之一。那么，为什么成年人道歉会这么难呢？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We all do things we regret or wish we could undo. And we all know how tempting it can be to deny the harm we have done, or shift blame to someone else, even though this can often make things worse. Psychologist Tyler Okimoto of the University of Queensland in Australia has studied why it's so difficult for us to admit we've done something wrong, and then to apologize. Tyler, you've looked at what happens when people do something wrong and then refuse to say they're sorry. Tell me about the studies you've conducted
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们都会做一些让我们感到后悔或希望能够撤销的事情。我们也都知道，否认我们造成的伤害或将责任推卸给别人是多么诱人，尽管这往往会让事情变得更糟。澳大利亚昆士兰大学的心理学家泰勒·奥基莫托研究了为什么我们很难承认自己做错了事，然后向人道歉。泰勒，你研究了当人们做错了事却拒绝道歉时会发生什么。请告诉我你所进行的那些研究
and how refusing to apologize can affect people's self-esteem. Well, I think we've probably all experienced the kind of urge to not apologize. One of the things that happens when you apologize is actually you are relinquishing a bit of power and control in that situation by admitting that you've done something wrong, by saying that you're sorry,
以及拒绝道歉是如何影响人们的自尊心的。嗯，我想我们大概都体验过那种不想道歉的冲动。当你道歉时发生的事情之一，其实是你通过承认自己做错了事、通过说对不起，在某种程度上放弃了在那种情况下的部分权力和控制权，
in a way you're handing over the opportunity for forgiveness to the other person. So it's no longer in my control to decide whether or not I'm a person of good moral standing. It's now in your hands for you to decide whether or not I'm worthy of forgiveness. And tell me about the experiments that you've done that have explored this idea, the experiments that have looked at both the issues of control and the issue of self-esteem. So we conducted a series of experiments to really try to
在某种程度上，你把获得原谅的机会拱手交给了对方。因此，我是否是一个具有良好道德品质的人，不再由我来决定。现在决定我是否值得被原谅，权力掌握在你的手中。请告诉我你所做的探讨这一想法的实验，那些既探讨了控制权问题又探讨了自尊问题的实验。因此，我们进行了一系列实验，真正试图
understand the psychological experience of refusing to apologize. What we found was actually quite interesting when people came forward and essentially said that I do not apologize for what I've done. It actually resulted in a short-term boost in their reported self-esteem. They actually felt better about themselves following a refusal to apologize. Now, what we did in the research is really tried to understand why that boost occurred. And what we found was that when you've refused to apologize, it gives you a bit of a feeling of increased power and control in that situation.
理解拒绝道歉的心理体验。我们发现的结果其实相当有趣：当人们站出来，本质上说出“我不会为我所做的事道歉”时，这实际上导致了他们自我报告自尊心的短期飙升。在拒绝道歉之后，他们对自己的感觉实际上变好了。现在，我们在研究中所做的，是真正试图理解为什么会出现这种飙升。我们发现的是，当你拒绝道歉时，它会带给你一种在这类情况下权力感和控制力增强的感觉。
And at the same time, by digging in and saying, no, no, I've done the right thing, it actually gives a bit of a boost to your feelings of integrity as well. Mm. Mm. Mm. If you think about integrity, integrity is walking your talk
与此同时，通过坚持己见并说“不，不，我做的是对的”，它实际上也会对你的正直感起到一定的提升作用。嗯。嗯。嗯。如果你仔细想想正直，正直就是说到做到
when you apologize, you're saying, the way that I acted is not consistent with my values. And refusing to apologize really digs in. And so has that short-term beneficial effect to how you feel about yourself. Now, you can draw the wrong conclusion here. Tyler is not saying it's a good thing to refuse to apologize. He's explaining why refusing to apologize can give you a short term boost. When I first feature Tyler's research on NPR's morning edition, conservative talk show host Rush Limbaugh picked
当你道歉时，你是在说：我的行事方式与我的价值观不一致。而拒绝道歉则是坚守立场。因此，这会对你对自己的感觉产生短期的有益影响。现在，你可能会在这里得出错误的结论。泰勒并不是说拒绝道歉是一件好事。他是在解释为什么拒绝道歉能给你带来短期的提升。当我第一次在NPR的《早间新闻》栏目中报道泰勒的研究时，保守派脱口秀主持人拉什·林堡
up on the story. One of the researchers, Tyler Okimoto, explained his interpretation of the result this way. So when you refuse to apologize, it actually makes you feel more empowered. It makes you feel more dominant. It makes you feel less subservient. It makes you feel not guilty. As a professional broadcaster, I can tell you that there is an adage. Don't care what you do. Don't ever apologize. Never. It was actually quite interesting. My mother called me and said that my aunt had heard about my
注意到了这个故事。其中一位研究人员泰勒·奥基莫托这样解释他对结果的解读：因此，当你拒绝道歉时，它实际上会让你感到更有力量。它让你感到更具有支配力。它让你觉得不那么卑躬屈膝。它让你觉得没有罪恶感。作为一名职业广播员，我可以告诉你有一句行业格言：不管你做什么，千万不要道歉。绝不。这其实相当有趣。我母亲打电话给我，说我的阿姨在收音机里听到了我的
research on the radio and was so proud of me and I said, oh, I didn't know that she listened to NPR. And turns out it wasn't the NPR interview as Rich Limbaugh. So in some ways, what I hear you saying is that when we justify our behavior, it allows us in some ways to maintain our positive self-concept. And in some ways, it's acting almost like armor. Now, admittedly, this armor might slow us down. It might prevent us from doing
研究，并为我感到骄傲。我说，哦，我不知道她听NPR。结果发现，那个采访不是NPR的，而是里绍·林堡（注：此处采访嘉宾口误将Rush Limbaugh说成了Rich Limbaugh）的。所以在某种程度上，我听到你所说的是，当我们为自己的行为辩解时，它在某种程度上使我们能够维持积极的自我概念。在某种程度上，它几乎就像是一副盔甲。当然，必须承认，这副盔甲可能会让我们慢下来。它可能会阻止我们去做
some things, but the impulse to dodge might actually come from this, perhaps, understandable desire to protect our self-concept. That's right. In the face of a threat, our natural psychological reaction is to protect the self. The challenge then is that our self-concept is also not just about who we are as individuals, but also our relationships and how we engage with other people and who we are as a group member, and our immediate reaction to protect our self, our personal self sometimes comes at a cost of our social self and our relationships. I want to play you a clip that I came by recently.
某些事情，但逃避的冲动实际上可能源于这种或许可以理解的保护我们自我概念的愿望。没错。面对威胁时，我们自然的心理反应是保护自我。随之而来的挑战是，我们的自我概念不仅关乎我们作为个体的身份，还关乎我们的关系、我们与他人的互动方式以及我们作为群体成员的身份，而我们保护自我的即时反应——我们的个人自我——有时是以牺牲我们的社会自我和我们的人际关系为代价的。我想放一段我最近偶然看到的小视频。
The TV talk show host Ellen DeGeneres came on the fire some time ago for presiding over what some employees called a toxic workplace. Here's a clip of Ellen talking about these charges on the today show. I am a kind person. I am a person who likes to make people happy. I am a people pleaser, you know, this is who I am. And so when I started hearing, you know, reading ridiculous things, and then it just kept going,
电视脱口秀主持人艾伦·德杰尼勒斯一段时间前陷入了舆论风暴，因为她主持的工作场所被一些员工称为“有毒的工作场所”。以下是艾伦在《今日秀》节目中谈论这些指控的片段。我是一个善良的人。我是一个喜欢让别人快乐的人。我是一个取悦他人的人，你知道，这就是我。所以当我开始听到，你知道的，读到荒谬的事情，然后它一直持续下去，
and going, and going, and going, that made me think someone's trying to really hurt me. And then right on the heels of that, I hear in the, I read in the press that there's a toxic work environment, which, I mean, I had no idea. So we talked a second ago about how we sometimes, you know, build up armor to protect our self-concept.
持续下去，持续下去，持续下去，这让我觉得有人真的在试图伤害我。紧接着，我在新闻里听到、读到那里有一个有毒的工作环境，而这，我的意思是，我一无所知。所以我们刚才讨论了我们有时如何，你知道的，建立盔甲来保护我们的自我概念。
But I want to explore the idea that one reason apologizing can be hard is because in some ways we have a self-concept that is very positive. Now, you know, Ellen has disputed some of the charges made about her workplace and I don't want to get into who's right or what happened in this particular workplace. But for our purposes here, I'm struck by her language. She's telling us, I'm a kind person,
但我想探讨这样一个观点：道歉之所以困难的原因之一，是因为在某种程度上，我们拥有一个非常积极的自我概念。现在，你知道，艾伦对针对她的工作场所的一些指控提出了异议，我不想卷入谁对谁错或这个特定工作场所发生了什么。但出于我们这里的目的，她的语言深深打动了我。她告诉我们：我是一个善良的人，
I'm a people pleaser. How could I possibly have presided over a toxic workplace? Is it possible tighter that in some ways our positive self-concept itself can become a barrier to apologizing? Yeah, absolutely. We get through life functionally because we can think about ourselves in a positive way. And that is part of who we are. A parallel that I like to talk about when I'm teaching is the idea of being a good leader. So I think of myself as a good leader, but good leaders actually sit back, reflect, and think about when they haven't been a good leader. What makes a good leader is somebody who's reflective.
我是一个取悦他人的人。我怎么可能主持一个有毒的工作场所呢？泰勒，有没有可能在某种程度上，我们积极的自我概念本身就会成为道歉的障碍？是的，绝对会。我们在生活中能够正常前行，是因为我们能够以积极的方式看待自己。这是我们身份的一部分。我在教学时喜欢谈论的一个相似类比是“成为一名好领导”的概念。因此，我认为自己是一个好领导，但好领导实际上会坐下来反思，并思考他们什么时候没有当好领导。什么样的人才是好领导？是一个懂得反思的人。
Same sort of situation here. Being a moral person is about being able to stop, reflect on your behavior, and come to a judgment about whether or not what you've done is reflective of who you want to be, and what your values are. And when that break is there, when there's a gap, being a moral person is about acknowledging that and apologizing if that's appropriate. It's interesting then that when people are justifying their behavior, I mean, it sounds like they're justifying their behavior to us, but it seems to me that it's also possible
这里的情况也完全一样。一个有道德的人，在于能够停下来，反思自己的行为，并对自己的所作所为是否反映了你想成为的人以及你的价值观做出判断。当这种中断存在时，当存在差距时，一个有道德的人就会去承认这一点，并在合适的情况下道歉。那么有趣的是，当人们为自己的行为辩解时，我的意思是，听起来他们是在向我们辩解，但在我看来，也有可能
then that they're actually justifying their behavior to themselves. Yeah, that's right. It seems to me that it's also possible then that they're actually justifying their behavior to themselves. Yeah, that's right. When we're being threatened, when we're being questioned, we try to defend our self-esteem because we don't want to feel bad about ourselves. Nobody likes feeling bad on an ongoing basis. And then when given the opportunity
实际上他们是在向自己辩解。是的，没错。当我们受到威胁，当我们受到质疑时，我们试图捍卫自己的自尊，因为我们不想对自己的感觉变差。没有人喜欢一直持续不断地感觉糟糕。然后，当有机会
to have a conversation that immediate self-forgiveness can come out. I'm wondering, have you seen this in your own life, Tyler, as somebody who studies apologies? Have you noticed that your own self-concept as a kind person or an empathetic person that this is sometimes perhaps kept you from apologizing or acknowledging harms that you have done? Well, it's funny that you say that because I tend to think of myself as somebody who does apologize when I do things wrong. But then of course with the question you just asked previously, it also makes me think, oh, okay, so maybe I'm just a self-justifier.
进行对话时，这种即时的自我原谅就会显现出来。泰勒，作为一名研究道歉的人，你是否在自己的生活中看到过这一点？你有没有注意到，你作为一个善良的人或富有同理心的人的自我概念，有时或许曾阻止你道歉或承认你所造成的伤害？嗯，你这么说真有意思，因为我倾向于认为自己是一个在做错事时会道歉的人。但当然，通过你刚才提出的问题，这也让我想到，哦，好吧，所以也许我只是一个自我辩解者。
I can't actually see. Maybe I'm not good at apologies. I just think that I am because I'm just a self-justifier. I can't actually see. Maybe I'm not good at apologies. I just think that I am because I'm that arrogant. I'm not quite sure which one it is. I want to just pause for one second and flag one thing, which is, you know, it is the case that sometimes people, in fact, are accused of things by mistake or they're falsely accused of something. So it cannot be that the only appropriate thing to do when you're accused of something is to apologize for it. We had
我实际上看不清。也许我并不擅长道歉。我只是认为自己擅长，因为我只是一个自我辩解者。我其实看不清。也许我并不擅长道歉。我只是认为自己擅长，因为我就是这么傲慢。我不太确定到底是哪一种。我想暂停一秒钟，指出一件事，那就是，有时候人们确实是被冤枉的，或者他们被虚假指控了某些事情。因此，当你被指控某事时，唯一正确的做法绝不可能是为此道歉。我们
a story on Hidden Brain featuring a man named Fred Clay who was charged and convicted of murder when he was a teenager. And he maintained his innocence and he said that he hadn't committed the crime. But when he was finally brought before the judge for sentencing, the fact that he did not express remorse, the fact that he did not apologize for what the court had convicted him of doing,
在《隐藏的大脑》中报道过一个名叫弗雷德·克莱的男人的故事，他在十几岁时被指控并判定犯有谋杀罪。他坚称自己是无辜的，并说自己没有犯罪。但当他最终被带到法官面前等待判决时，他没有表现出悔意，他没有为法庭判定他做过的事情道歉，
that gave the judge reason to essentially lock him up and throw away the key. And as it turned out, Fred Clay spent several decades in prison, always maintaining his innocence. And finally, his trial was thrown out and he was recently exonerated. And it just leads me to think that it cannot be
这给了法官把他在监狱里关起来并扔掉钥匙的理由。事实证明，弗雷德·克莱在监狱里度过了几十年，一直坚称自己无罪。最后，他的审判被推翻，他最近被宣告无罪。这不禁让我觉得，
that the answer to an accusation always is an apology. This is what makes it confusing. Sometimes, saying, I didn't do it, might actually be the right thing to say. Psychologically, we want to hear that the person that we're accusing is remorseful and that they admit what they've done is wrong. But you're right in that that's not always the case. And I think this is where the challenging situation that we tend to be in these days
对指控的回应绝不可能是千篇一律的道歉。这就是让人感到困惑的地方。有时，说“我没做过”，实际上可能是正确的话。从心理学上讲，我们希望听到我们所指控的人表现出悔意，并承认他们所做的是错误的。但你说得对，情况并非总是如此。我认为这就是我们这些天往往陷入的具有挑战性的局面，
is that a lot of these sorts of cases are, at least the ones that we read about, are quite high profile. And the accused individual is actually being in a way judged not just by the victim, but also by the court system, also by the media, also by the public who consumes that media. And the reason why the media tends to pick these things up is because they are symbolic of a bigger problem, right? The judge Floyd case was interesting to people because it was about systemic racism. The MeToo movement, the media is interested because it's beyond that individual offender and victim. It becomes symbolic of the broader systemic problem. And they get judged on this, you know, basically on this, this higher level. Let me see if I'm understanding what you're saying, Tyler, you're saying that in some of these cases, the cases themselves
那就是许多这类案件，至少是我们读到的那些，都相当引人注目。而且被指控的个人不仅受到受害者的审判，还受到法院系统的审判，受到媒体的审判，也受到消费这些媒体的公众的审判。媒体之所以倾向于挑选这些事情来报道，是因为它们象征着一个更大的问题，对吧？弗洛伊德法官的案件之所以受人关注，是因为它关乎系统性种族主义。至于#MeToo运动，媒体之所以感兴趣，是因为它超越了个别的违规者和受害者。它成了更广泛系统性问题的象征。人们在（你知道的，基本上是）这个更高层面上对他们进行审判。让我看看我是否理解了你的意思，泰勒，你是说在其中一些案件中，案件本身
become a stand-in for something bigger than just a case itself. But if you're one of these individuals who gets caught up in one of these symbolic cases, it's perhaps understandable that you might say, hang on a second, don't put all of that on me. I'm just an individual here. This is just the fact of this case is all that we should be paying attention to,
变成了一种比案件本身更大的事物的代名词。但如果你是卷入这些象征性案件的个人之一，那么你或许可以理解你会说：“等一下，别把所有这些都压在我身上。我这里只是一个个案。这个案件的事实才应该是我们应该关注的全部，
not sort of that grander, bigger symbolic story. That's right. In many of these situations it's the historical problem that is being tried at least in the public's eyes. We hope that our court system can get past that and make it really about the individuals involved. But when things are being tried in the media it really is that bigger symbolic meaning that is really driving the strength of people's reactions. So it's interesting these conversations are actually happening at multiple levels, right?
而不是那种更宏大、更庞大的象征性故事。”没错。在许多情况下，至少在公众眼中，受审的是历史问题。我们希望我们的法院系统能够超越这一点，真正关注所涉及的个人。但当事情在媒体上受审时，真正推动人们反应强度的是那种更大的象征意义。所以有趣的是，这些对话实际上是在多个层面进行的，对吧？
So from a, when you have a police shooting, for example, the victim's family might say, you know, this is part of a larger system of injustice that has existed for many years, many decades. From the point of view of the police officer who did the shooting, the police officer might say, this was an individual case, and we have to look at just the facts of this individual case and what the evidence says. And the fact that one side is having a conversation about something that is structurally wrong, and the other side is having an argument about an individual case.
所以从……比如发生警察枪击事件时，受害者的家属可能会说：“你知道，这是多年、数十年一直存在的更大不公正系统的一部分。”从开枪警察的角度来看，警察可能会说：“这是一个个案，我们必须只看这个个案的事实和证据所说的话。”而事实是，一方在谈论结构性错误的事情，而另一方在争论一个具体的个案。
This might be part of the reason we often have mismatches in our public conversations about these cases. So when the courts, for example, have exonerated police officers in some of these shootings, people feel the courts now must be part of the problem as well, without necessarily taking into account that what the courts are set up to do is not, in some ways, try the symbolic case or the larger case, but essentially the facts of the very narrow case that's just in front of them. You know, in fact, we've done a little bit of research on this exact question. We like to talk about it as the appraisal gap.
这可能是我们对这些案件的公开对话中经常出现错位的部分原因。因此，举例来说，当法院在其中一些枪击事件中宣判警察无罪时，人们会觉得法院现在肯定也是问题的一部分，却没有 necesariamente考虑到法院的设定目的在某种程度上并不是审判象征性案件或更大的案件，而是本质上审判他们面前非常狭隘的案件的事实。你知道，事实上，我们确实围绕这个确切的问题做了一些研究。我们喜欢把它称为“评估差距”。
What we tend to find is that when you're the member of a victim group, so when you're a woman seeing the MeToo situation unfold, when you're an African-American viewing black lives matters issues that you see in that those individual cases, you see the systemic problem and as a consequence, the solution to those individual cases is a broader systemic solution. However, from the offender groups perspective, when I see something going wrong in my own group, then a bit of a self-protective mechanism here as well, tend to think of it as, okay, well, that's just a bad apple. And so what you tend to get as a gap between a victim group that believes
我们往往发现，当你是一个受害者群体的成员时——当你是一个看到#MeToo事件展开的女性，当你是一个看到黑人生命也是命（Black Lives Matter）问题的非裔美国人时——在那些个案中，你看到的是系统性问题，因此，解决这些个案的方案就是一个更广泛的系统性方案。然而，从加害者群体的角度来看，当我在我自己的群体中看到某些事情出问题时，这里也存在一种自我保护机制，倾向于认为：“哦，好吧，那只是一颗坏苹果。”所以你往往会得到这样一个差距：一个受害者群体认为
that a systemic solution is necessary and really a group level apology gap between a victim group that believes that a systemic solution is necessary and, and really a group level apology for talking about apologies versus an offender group that doesn't necessarily believe that there's a systemic problem, that believes that the right thing to do is to deal with the individual, punish that individual, and to have an individual level apology. Right. This is perhaps why group leaders sometimes come out
系统性方案是必要的，并且真正存在群体层面的道歉差距——一边是认为系统性方案是必要的受害者群体，以及真正的群体层面道歉；而另一边是加害者群体，他们不一定认为存在系统性问题，他们认为正确的事情是处理个人、惩罚该个人，并进行个人层面的道歉。对吧。这或许就是为什么群体领导人有时会站出来
and say that mistakes were made. Not, we collectively made a mistake. Clearly mistakes were made. Mistakes were made here. And he's right, mistakes were made. Terrible mistakes were made. How do these mismatches and expectations shape when apologies are demanded, how they are
说“犯了错误”。而不是“我们集体犯了一个错误”。“显然犯了错误”。“这里犯了错误”。他是对的，确实犯了错误。犯下了可怕的错误。这些对期望的错位是如何塑造道歉的需求、它们是如何
offered, and whether they are accepted? Tyler and other researchers have found that people nowadays increasingly have a greater appetite for apologies. We want to see people come forward and say, I'm sorry. But in an experiment, Tyler discovered something curious that comes about as a result of our heightened expectations for apologies. What we found is at the same time decreasing their satisfaction when actually receiving it. I have to ask you, though, because I feel like I can see sort of a flip side to this,
提出的，以及它们是否被接受的呢？泰勒和其他研究人员发现，如今人们对道歉的渴望越来越强烈。我们希望看到人们站出来说：“我很抱歉。”但在一个实验中，泰勒发现了由于我们对道歉的期望提高而带来的一个奇特结果。我们发现，与此同时，当真正收到道歉时，他们的满意度却在下降。不过我不得不问你，因为我觉得我能看到这种情况的另一面，
which is that if we are as a society less accepting of apologies, in other words, someone comes forward, does the right thing, does the difficult thing, and apologizes, and we basically say, no thanks, that wasn't good enough. Doesn't that create a disincentive for people to actually apologize? And I feel like I see this in politicians increasingly when they're accused of things, they're increasingly saying the smart play here is in fact not to apologize because falling on your sword effectively accomplishes nothing. Is there a risk that in some ways are unwillingness to accept apologies can perversely cause us to actually receive fewer apologies? Yeah, that's a fair point.
那就是，如果作为一个社会，我们对道歉的接受度降低了——换句话说，某人站出来，做了正确的事，做了困难的事并进行了道歉，而我们基本上说：“不用了谢谢，这还不够好”——这难道不会对人们实际进行道歉产生一种负面激励吗？我觉得我越来越多地看到政治人物在受到指控时，他们越来越倾向于认为明智的做法其实是不要道歉，因为向宝剑倒下（引咎辞职）实际上毫无用处。是否存在这样一种风险：我们在某种程度上不愿意接受道歉，反而会反常地导致我们实际上收到更少的道歉？是的，这倒是个好观点。
You know, if the purpose of an apology is to overcome the problem is to make the victim forgive you, then yes, this does suggest that maybe the pay-off or an apology is not as great as we think it is. In fact, particularly in intergroup context, these big systemic problems, we do tend to find that apologies for these big historical problems don't actually have that much of a positive impact
你知道，如果道歉的目的是克服问题、让受害者原谅你，那么是的，这确实表明道歉的回报可能不像我们想象的那么大。事实上，尤其是在群体间的情境下，这些重大的历史问题，我们确实往往发现，针对这些重大历史问题的道歉实际上并没有产生那么大的正面影响
on how the victim group feels and whether or not the victim group is willing to forgive. However, I suppose the other side of this is that that's assuming that the particular outcome is the purpose of an apology. So if the purpose of an apology is to get forgiveness, is to make the other person feel better and to feel better as yourself than yes, they are losing their power. Right. If the purpose of the apology is because it's the right thing to do, because it makes you better as a person, because it makes our society better. If that's the purpose of an apology, then it doesn't matter whether or not it follows with forgiveness, or it follows with reduction in sentencing, or if it follows in reduction of your feelings of guilt,
——对于受害者群体的感受以及受害者群体是否愿意原谅。然而，我想另一面是，这假设了特定的结果就是道歉的目的。所以，如果道歉的目的是为了获得原谅，是为了让对方感觉更好、让你自己感觉更好，那么是的，它们正在失去力量。对吧。如果道歉的目的仅仅是因为这是正确的事，因为它让你成为一个更好的人，因为它让我们的社会变得更好——如果那是道歉的目的，那么它是否伴随着原谅、是否伴随着减刑、或者是否伴随着你内疚感的减少，这都无关紧要，
it's still the right thing to do. It's hard to admit that we're wrong. It's easy to feel our own pain, but much harder to see the pain we cause others. The psychological barriers to apologizing make it easier for all of us to ignore and justify and minimize wrongdoing. When we come back, why it makes sense to apologize even when forgiveness might not be forthcoming.
它依然是正确的事情。承认我们错了很难。去感受自己的痛苦很容易，但要看到我们给别人造成的痛苦却难得多。道歉的心理障碍使我们所有人更容易忽视、合理化和淡化不当行为。当我们回来时，我们将探讨为什么即使在可能不会得到原谅的情况下道歉也是有意义的。
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We've talked about some of the internal and external obstacles to apologizing. Why not apologizing can sometimes feel good, and how admitting that we've done someone wrong can threaten our positive view of ourselves. And we've looked at the gaps in perception between victims and transgressors that can cause apologies, even genuine apologies, to be ignored or dismissed.
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们讨论了道歉的一些内在和外在障碍。为什么不道歉有时会感觉很好，以及承认我们对不起别人如何会威胁到我们对自己的积极看法。我们还探讨了受害者与加害者之间在认知上的差距，这些差距可能导致道歉——甚至是真诚的道歉——被忽视或驳回。
At the University of Queensland in Australia, psychologist Tyler Okimoto does more than explore all the ways apologies don't work or can go wrong. He also looks at when apologies work, how to apologize better, and why we should. Tyler, you ran an experiment that measured how likely people were to think an apology was genuine, and you found a connection with the expression of remorse. Can you tell me what you found? You know, one of the things that people are really looking for in a apology is a sincere belief that the individual who's apologizing is
在澳大利亚昆士兰大学，心理学家泰勒·奥基莫托不仅仅是探索道歉不起作用或出错的种种方式。他还研究道歉何时起作用、如何更好地道歉，以及我们为什么要这样做。泰勒，你曾做过一个实验，测量人们认为道歉真诚的可能性，你发现这与悔意的表达之间存在联系。你能告诉我你发现了什么吗？你知道，人们在道歉中真正寻找的东西之一，是对正在道歉的个人对其行为感到
remorseful for their actions. In fact, judgements of remorse and sincerity of that remorse are really influential in changing whether or not people are willing to forgive after an apology. What kind of expressions have remorse to do study? So we looked at a bunch of different sorts of expressions. You know we looked at traditional apologies so the words that people say and the meaning behind them. We also looked at physical displays, things like tears, things like your body posture, in a way, those nonverbal gestures are apparently a little bit involuntary. And so when you see individuals seeming to lose control with their emotions, with their
悔恨的真诚信仰。事实上，对悔意以及这种悔意真诚性的判断，在改变人们在道歉后是否愿意原谅方面确实具有很大的影响力。你研究了哪种悔意的表达？因此，我们研究了一堆不同类型的表达。你知道，我们研究了传统的道歉，也就是人们说的话以及话背后的含义。我们还研究了身体表现，比如眼泪，比如你的身体姿态——在某种程度上，那些非言语的手势显然有点不由自主。因此，当你看到个人似乎在情绪上失控时，伴随着他们
feelings of remorse and regret, then it signals to us that what they're saying is actually true. In fact, it's so true that they're losing control, they're crying, they're flopping over in a gesture of submission. So that's what makes a good apology is all of the pieces around it, not just the words themselves. I'm thinking of a study by Alison Woodbroke who examined apologies at parole hearings for crimes ranging from speeding to murder. And she found apologies with a promise of good future behavior were more effective, whereas
对悔恨和遗憾的感觉，这就向我们发出了一个信号，表明他们所说的话其实是真的。事实上，它是如此真实，以至于他们正在失控，他们在哭泣，他们在做着顺从的手势俯伏在地。所以，这就是造就一个好道歉的周围所有元素，而不仅仅是话语本身。我想到了艾森·伍德布罗克（Allison Woodbrook）的一项研究，他考察了假释听证会上从超速到谋杀等各种犯罪的道歉。他发现带有未来良好行为承诺的道歉更有效，而
apologies that included an explanation of why the transgression occurred tended to be ineffective. What is that telling us, Tyler? That finding is actually quite consistent with what we find in the psychology literature. There's really two aspects to the reconciliation process. There's the backward looking, trying to make sense and come to a shared understanding about what happened, trying to understand the other person's perspective on what happened, trying to share your own perspective on what happened, and come to some agreement about what the offense was itself and what my
包含对为什么发生违规行为进行解释的道歉往往效果不佳。泰勒，这说明了什么？这一发现实际上与我们在心理学文献中发现的内容相当一致。和解过程其实有两个方面。一个是向后看的，试图理解并就发生的事情达成共识，试图理解对方对所发生事情的视角，试图分享你自己的视角，并就违背行为本身以及我对其中的
responsibility was in that. Then the other half of it is a forward thinking, the future focused aspect of the apology, which is really what's going to happen from now on. What people are often looking for is a promise of future behavior. And some action that begins to evidence your willingness to move towards that future behavior. The research of Cindy France found that apologizing too early can make apologies less effective. What's going on here, Tyler? If you apologize in a knee-jerk sort of way, then it really does come off like a knee jerk apology. But at the same time, if you do delay too long,
责任达成某种协议。然后，另一半是向前看的，是道歉中面向未来的方面，这实际上关乎从今以后会发生什么。人们经常寻找的是对未来行为的承诺。以及开始证明你愿意朝着该未来行为迈进的某种行动。辛迪·弗兰斯（Cindy France）的研究发现，过早道歉会降低道歉的效果。泰勒，这里是怎么回事？如果你以一种膝跳反射式的方式道歉，那么它确实会给人一种膝跳反射式道歉的感觉。但与此同时，如果你拖延太久，
I'm then apologized later on down the track. It really comes off as, oh well, they tried to get away with not apologizing, but then finally cave to the pressure. And so there does seem to be some sweet spot about where the apology should occur. In some of the research that we've done, we actually looked at this timing pattern
然后在稍后的时间点再道歉。这就真的会给人一种感觉：“哦，好吧，他们试图逃避道歉，但最后还是向压力屈服了。”因此，道歉应该在何时发生，似乎确实存在一个最佳时机。在我们做过的一些研究中，我们实际上研究了群体间道歉中的这种时间模式。
within intergroup apologies. And what we found is this problem with delays to where if you wait too long, it comes off as cold and calculated and insincere, and you only did it because you had to. But we did find a little bit of an antidote if the offender group, the transgressor group, did it because you had to, but we did find a little bit of an antidote. If the offender group, the transgressor group, is using that time for something
我们发现的问题是关于拖延的，如果你等得太久，它就会显得冷酷、计算精密且不真诚，你这么做只是因为你不得不这么做。但我们确实发现了一点解毒剂，如果加害者群体、违规群体——你这么做只是因为你不得不这么做，但我们确实发现了一点解毒剂。如果加害者群体、违规群体正在利用这段时间做一些
positive, is using that time to reflect, then that delay can actually turn out to be a good thing. Right, so for example, if in the apology you say, I know it's been a few weeks, the reason why we took that time is because we wanted to really understand the victims and really speak with them to recognize and understand their perspectives before we could make an appropriate response. So in that sense, then that delay can be a good thing. But in absence of that, in absence of an explanation, then it can be problematic. It's really interesting, Tyler, because as you're talking, I'm seeing how complex
积极的事情，正在利用这段时间进行反思，那么这种拖延实际上可能会变成一件好事。对吧，所以举个例子，如果在道歉中你说：“我知道已经过去几个星期了，我们花那段时间的原因是因为我们真的想了解受害者，并真正与他们交谈，在做出恰当的回应之前认识并理解他们的视角。”从这个意义上说，这种拖延可能是一件好事。但在没有这种情况、没有解释的情况下，它就会成问题。泰勒，这真的很有趣，因为当你在说话时，我看到了这个问题的复杂性，
this issue is, because the line between what makes sense and what's effective and what's ineffective is actually quite thin, right? So in other words, on the one hand, apologizing too soon can be a problem, and apologizing too late can be a problem, and apologizing too late can be a problem. Some researchers found that when you justify or explain your behavior and talk about your intentions
因为什么是有意义的、什么是有效的与什么是无效的之间的界限其实非常薄，对吧？所以换句话说，一方面，过早道歉可能是个问题，而过早道歉可能是个问题，而且过晚道歉也可能是个问题。一些研究发现，当你为自己的行为辩解或解释并谈论你的意图时
and say that I actually didn't mean to do this, that can have a bad effect, and other research suggests that it actually is helpful to put context to the situation and say, this is not what I intended to do. I know that I caused harm, but that it was not my intention. It almost feels like it's, for every argument you can make about what makes a good apology, there's another piece of research that basically says you have to do precisely
并说我其实并非故意这么做，这可能会产生不好的效果。而其他研究表明，为这种情况提供背景信息并说“这不是我本意，我知道我造成了伤害，但这并非我的本意”实际上是有帮助的。这给人的感觉几乎是，关于什么构成一个好的道歉，你提出的每一个论点，都会有另一项研究基本上说你必须做完全
the opposite. Yeah, well, it is complicated. In fact, this is why I personally find it so interesting and challenging is because it's sufficiently complex that there is no formula. Yeah. You know, there's writing out there that will say to have an effective apology, you need these five things or you need the seven steps to this.
相反的事情。是的，这很复杂。事实上，这也是为什么我个人觉得它如此有趣且充满挑战，因为它足够复杂，以至于没有一个公式。是的。你知道，外界有一些文章会说，要进行一次有效的道歉，你需要这五件事或需要七个步骤。
That might be true in a general sense, but every situation is different. And the same apology, the same structure of apology, the same components are not going to be similarly effective in all situations. It also means that once you've apologized, you also need to reflect a little bit. Maybe it wasn't good enough. If you apologize and it's not accepted, try to learn from that, try to understand what it is that is needed, try to understand the other person's perspective or the other group's perspective.
这在宏观意义上可能是对的，但每种情况都是不同的。同样的道歉，同样的道歉结构，同样的组成部分，在所有情况下都不会有同样的效果。这也意味着，一旦你道了歉，你也需要进行一些反思。也许这还不够好。如果你道歉了却没有被接受，试着从中吸取教训，试着理解需要的是什么，试着理解另一个人的视角或另一个群体的视角。
It's interesting because I think when we see people sort of revising their apologies, our instinct is often to say, well, this person is just, you know, caving to pressure, or they're basically, you know, they're finally being brought to their senses to do what they should have done in the first place. But I suppose a more compassionate way to look at it is to say that sometimes it does take people some time to actually understand what they have done. And in some ways the fact that people are revising their positions should not be seen as a bad thing, it might actually maybe we should say it as a good thing.
这很有趣，因为我认为当我们看到人们修改他们的道歉时，我们的直觉往往是说，这个人只是（你知道的）向压力屈服了，或者他们基本上（你知道的）终于清醒过来，去做他们一开始就应该做的事情。但我想，更具同情心的看法是，有时人们确实需要一些时间来真正理解他们所做的事情。在某种程度上，人们在修改他们的立场不应被视为一件坏事，事实上，也许我们应该把它视为一件好事。
Yeah, that's right. In fact, you know, some of the research that we're doing currently is really looking at diet. So a victim and a fender diet, and trying to understand how the apology and the forgiveness go together. And what we're actually finding is that, we tend to think about these things as, something's done wrong, you apologize, you forgive, and then everyone shakes hands and moves on. In reality, how these things evolve over time
是的，确实如此。事实上，你知道，我们目前正在做的一些研究确实在关注这种动态。也就是受害者和加害者的动态，并试图理解道歉和原谅是如何结合在一起的。而我们实际发现的是，我们倾向于将这些事情视为：某人做错了事，你道歉，你原谅，然后大家握手言和，继续前进。实际上，这些事情是如何随着时间演变的
is that something's done wrong, you know, the victim expresses the needs that they have in the situation, the offender tries to respond with something resembling an apology, the victim then gives, you know, reacts to that. And then of course, the offender then revises what they've said.
是这样的：某人做错了事，（你知道的）受害者在当时的情境下表达他们的需求，加害者试图用类似于道歉的东西来回应，接着受害者（你知道的）对此做出反应。然后当然，加害者会修改他们说过的话。
And so really reconciliation is an unfolding process, an unfolding process that's about what's going on inside the offender's head as well as what they're communicating, but also what's going on inside the victim's head and what it is that they're communicating as well. You know, it's so interesting we spoke with the psychologist Charlotte Whitfleet some time ago, and she was talking about the psychology of forgiveness, and she said something that was almost eerily similar to what you're saying, which is that forgiveness is not typically a one-half decision. Like someone says something to you, you say, okay, I forgive you, and you know, case closed
所以真正的和解是一个展开的过程，一个关于加害者脑海中在想什么以及他们在传达什么，同时也关于受害者脑海中在想什么以及他们也在传达什么的一个展开的过程。你知道，这太有趣了，不久前我们和心理学家夏洛特·惠特弗利（Charlotte Whitfleet）交谈过，她谈到了原谅的心理学，她说的话几乎与你所说的惊人相似，那就是原谅通常不是一个半途而废的决定。就像某人对你说了什么，你说，好吧，我原谅你，然后（你知道的）案件就了结了
and we all move on, but it's much more of this unfolding dance, if you will, that involves multiple steps back and forth, and it often unfolds over a long period of time. Yeah, that's right. And sometimes you don't know what the victim's needs are. And so the offender also needs to engage in that process to understand what the issues are and how to best respond to them. If I give my own conversations with my wife, you know, sometimes I don't understand why she's upset about something and so my apology might not be appropriate.
大家各自前行，但如果你愿意的话，它更像是一场展开的舞蹈，涉及来来回回的多个步骤，并且通常在一个较长的时期内展开。是的，确实如此。有时你并不知道受害者的需求是什么。因此，加害者也需要参与到这个过程中，以了解问题所在以及如何以最佳方式回应他们。如果拿我和我妻子的对话来举例，（你知道的）有时我不明白她为什么为某事心烦意乱，所以我的道歉可能并不恰当。
It's really through that conversation and that understanding over time that we come to realize why it is that the other person is really upset. And only then can we respond in a way that is appropriate for their needs in the situation. I want to talk a moment about collective apologies and apologies on a larger scale. On January 30th 1972, British paratroopers opened fire on protesters in Northern Ireland and they killed 13 protesters. The event came to be known as Bloody Sunday. 13 protesters, the event came to be known as Bloody Sunday. 38 years later, the British Prime Minister David Cameron offered the following apology. I never want to believe anything bad about our country.
正是通过这种对话和随着时间的理解，我们才开始意识到为什么另一个人会真正心烦意乱。只有这样，我们才能以适合他们在当时情况下的需求的方式作出回应。我想花一点时间谈谈集体道歉和大范围的道歉。1972年1月30日，英国伞兵在北爱尔兰向抗议者开枪，杀害了13名抗议者。这一事件后来被称为“血腥星期日”。13名抗议者，这一事件后来被称为“血腥星期日”。38年后，英国首相大卫·卡梅伦发表了以下道歉。我从来不想相信关于我们国家的任何坏事。
I never want to call into question the behaviour of our soldiers and our army, who I believe to be the finest in the world. But the conclusions of this report are absolutely clear. yn y fwyfnwyr. Mae'r cyflwyngor y fwyfnwyr yn fwyfnwnd ind i'n mynd ind i'n mynd i'n mynd i'n mynd i'n mynd i of that day and with a lifetime of loss. The government is ultimately responsible for the conduct of the armed forces and for that, on behalf of the government, indeed on behalf of our country, I am deeply sorry. So Tyler you've cited the speech as a powerful example of a great apology. What do you think makes it effective? The sincerity that you can hear in David Cameron's voice, the words in fully accepting responsibility, it was particularly powerful, I think, because he was speaking out in a way against the opinions and views of past political leaders to say that, no, no, we've actually looked at it.
我从来不想质疑我们的士兵和军队的行为，我认为他们是世界上最好的。但这份报告的结论是绝对明确的。（注：此处原文包含了一句威尔士语，根据上下文语境或语音识别错误，通常指那一天以及一生的失落。）政府最终要对武装部队的行为负责，为此，我谨代表政府，乃至代表我们的国家，深表歉意。所以泰勒，你曾将这段演讲誉为伟大道歉的有力例证。你认为是什么让它如此有效？你从大卫·卡梅伦的声音中能听到的真诚，那些完全承担责任的词句，它之所以特别有力，我认为是因为他以一种打破过去政治领导人观点和看法的方式大声疾呼，表示不，不，我们其实已经审视过了。
And we are coming to terms with the fact that there is a responsibility here that needs to be accounted for. Yeah, I'm sort of, I'm not hearing minimization. I'm not hearing dodging. I'm not hearing hedging. I'm not hearing, well, I'm sorry if you felt bad about this, even though, I don't think there was anything wrong
并且我们正在接受这样一个事实，即这里存在着需要交代和承担的责任。是的，我有点，我没有听到淡化。我没有听到推卸。我没有听到逃避。我没有听到，嗯，如果你对此感到难过的话我很抱歉，尽管我不认为有任何不对的地方
that was done, I'm not hearing any of those things in this apology. The people that analyze these sorts of statements from a discourse perspective, really talk about the bluestunday apology of David Cameron's as really of top 10 apology ever given in history. So in that sense, the words themselves are really on point. Yeah. I want to play another clip of another famous apology. This one was from Ronald Reagan in 1988. Members of Congress and distinguished guests, we gather here today to write a grave wrong. More than 40 years ago, shortly after the bombing of Pearl Harbor,
被做了，我在这次道歉中没有听到任何这些东西。那些从话语角度分析这类声明的人，真的把大卫·卡梅伦的“血腥星期日”道歉称为历史上排名前10的道歉之一。从这个意义上说，这些话本身确实非常贴切。是的。我想播放另一个著名道歉的片段。这是罗纳德·里根在1988年发表的。国会成员和尊贵的来客，我们今天齐聚于此，是为了纠正一个严重的错误。40多年前，在珍珠港事件发生后不久，
120,000 persons of Japanese ancestry, living in the United States, were forcibly removed from their homes and placed in makeshift internment camps. This action was taken without trial, without jury. It was based solely on race, for these 120,000 were Americans of Japanese descent. Yes, the nation was then at war, struggling for its survival. And it's not for us today to pass judgment upon those who may have made mistakes while engaged in that great struggle. Yet we must recognize that the internment of Japanese Americans
居住在美国的12万有日本血统的人，被强行从家中带走，并安置在临时拘留营中。这一行动没有经过审判，没有陪审团。它纯粹基于种族，因为这12万人是具有日本血统的美国人。是的，当时国家正处于战争状态，为生存而苦苦挣扎。我们今天不应该对那些在参与那场伟大斗争时可能犯了错误的人评头论足。然而我们必须承认，拘留日裔美国人
was just that, a mistake. For throughout the war, Japanese Americans in the tens of thousands remained utterly loyal to the United States. So Tyler talk about this apology in the context of the one we heard from David Cameron. As I'm listening to it, I realize that it surely must help that the person making the apology is not the one who was responsible for the wrongdoing. David Cameron didn't order Bloody Sunday, Ronald Reagan didn't order the interment of Japanese Americans during World War II.
就是这样，一个错误。因为在整个战争期间，成千上万的日裔美国人对美国始终绝对忠诚。所以泰勒，请在我们在大卫·卡梅伦那里听到的道歉的背景下，谈谈这个道歉。当我聆听它时，我意识到，道歉的人不是对不当行为负责的人，这肯定会有所帮助。大卫·卡梅伦没有下令制造血腥星期日，罗纳德·里根也没有在二战期间下令拘留日裔美国人。
It certainly seems easier to apologize when you are not the person who is actually responsible for the harm. Yes, and a lot of these historical transgressions aren't spoken about until generations later in the majority of cases. This particular example that you're raising is somewhat personal to myself and that my lost name's Okomoto and I'm fourth generation American. And so I had relatives that not were interned but were told to leave California on threat of internment. And the same thing is true, I guess, on the victim side in that
当你不是那个真正对伤害负责的人时，道歉似乎确实更容易一些。是的，在大多数情况下，很多这样的历史违规行为直到几代人之后才被谈论。你提出的这个特殊例子对我和我来说有点私人意味，因为我的姓氏是奥科莫托（Okamoto），我是第四代美国人。因此，我有亲戚不是被拘留，而是被威胁如果不离开加州就会被拘留。我想，在受害者这一边也是一样的，因为
as a descendant of somebody that would have been affected by this decision, it's also easier for me as an individual to get to that point of forgiveness because there is some distance. And a really abstraction of the problem. It's a lot easier to see other perspectives when you have some distance, either for you, temporarily or in this case, generationally. Yeah. And so it's really not surprising that it, you know, sometimes takes decades for states, governments,
作为受此决定影响的某个人的后代，我作为个人也更容易达到宽恕的那一步，因为存在一些距离。以及对问题的某种抽象化。当你拥有一些距离时，无论是时间上的，还是在这种情况下代际上的，看到其他视角就会容易得多。是的。所以，（你知道的）国家、政府有时需要几十年的时间，这真的不足为奇，
to understand what is needed in that situation. And in fact, I, fact, it really takes time. We look at slavery as another example. Certain parts of the government have apologized for that, but not all parts of the government. In Australia, Tyler says the government has denoted a national day of repentance. It's called, sorry day. The idea is to apologize to Aboriginal people who had that children stolen from them over multiple decades in the 20th century. The abductions were carried out to assimilate children into mainstream white culture. The hurt, the humiliation, the degradation, and the sheer brutality of the act of physically
去理解在这种情况下需要什么。事实上，我，这确实需要时间。我们以奴役制度为例。政府的某些部门已经为此道歉了，但并非政府的所有部门都道歉了。在澳大利亚，泰勒说政府已经指定了一个国家忏悔日。它被称为“道歉日”。这个想法是向原住民道歉，在20世纪的几十年里，他们的孩子被多次剥夺。这些绑架是为了让儿童同化到主流白人文化中。伤害、羞辱、退化，以及纯粹残暴的实体行为——
separating a mother from her children is a deeper salt on our senses and on our most elemental humanity. Tyler has studied the effects of public demonstrations of remorse by ordinary Australians. The research that we've done on this is actually pointed to the fact that that sorry demonstration is really important, while government apologies are great from the victim's group perspective, what people want from the apology from these collective problems is really a belief that the offending group as a whole is remorseful. And so when you get, you know, thousands of people marching in the streets,
将母亲与孩子骨肉分离，是对我们感官和我们最基本人性的更深层次的侵犯。泰勒研究了普通澳大利亚人公开表达悔意的效果。我们对此所做的研究实际上指出，这种道歉的游行真的非常重要，虽然从受害者群体的角度来看，政府的道歉很好，但人们对这些集体问题的道歉真正想要的，是相信加害群体作为一个整体是感到悔恨的。所以当你有，（你知道的）成千上万的人走上街头，
saying how sorry they are for what happened, that's actually quite impactful, relative to just some politician who's getting up there and saying something for possibly political reasons. It's an acknowledgement of the wrongdoing that was committed to the stolen generations. It's something that needs to be remembered by everyone. It's an atrocity that happened in Australia's history. And for a non-indigenous person to learn a little bit, you know, a history about that, non-indigenous persons, to learn a little bit, you know, history about that. It will show you, or mean a lot to an Aboriginal person. It can help our people heal. You know, you hinted at something earlier in our conversation, Taita, that I want to
表达他们对所发生事情的歉意时，相对于那些可能出于政治原因而上台说些什么的政客来说，这实际上是非常具有影响力的。这是对被偷走的一代人所遭受的不当行为的承认。这是每个人都需要记住的事情。这是澳大利亚历史上发生的一场暴行。对于一个非原住民来说，去了解一点（你知道的）关于那段历史，非原住民去了解一点（你知道的）关于那段历史。它会向一个原住民展示，或者意味着很多。它能帮助我们的人民疗愈。泰勒，你在我们对话的早期暗示了一件事，我想
come back to, which is one reason to pursue apologies might not be necessarily because they have this instrumental effect on generating forgiveness. Because as we've seen, sometimes apologies are not crafted correctly. Sometimes the victims might not be in a position to hear the apology. Sometimes the apology might be insufficient to the harm that was done. There are all kinds of ways these misunderstandings could occur. But one idea that you hinted at that's really important is that our reluctance to offer apologies often comes down to protecting the self, whereas our willingness to offer apologies often comes down to our interest in protecting relationships. Can you talk
回到这个话题，寻求道歉的一个原因可能不一定是因为它们对产生原谅有这种工具性的效果。因为正如我们所看到的，有时道歉并没有正确制作。有时受害者可能无法听到道歉。有时道歉可能不足以弥补所造成的伤害。这些误解可能以各种方式发生。但你暗示的一个非常重要的观点是，我们不愿道歉往往归结为保护自我，而我们愿意道歉往往归结于我们对保护关系的兴趣。你能谈谈
about this distinction that in some ways the reason to offer apologies might not necessarily be because they're going to generate a forgiveness or get the answer that we want, but in some ways because you're trying to repair a bond that is afraid or broken. There's really two sides, two big elements, to what is lost in a transgression. So, on the one hand, a transgression threatens the relationship that threatens your shared identity, you know, who you are, you know, for talking about post-relationships. Who are you? Who you are as a couple, the values that you shared. On the other side, it also does threaten that status and power kind of hierarchy. So, you know, a transgression demeans the other party. It undermines them. It removes control.
这个区别吗：在某些情况下，道歉的原因不一定是因为它们会产生原谅或得到我们想要的答案，而是在某种程度上因为你试图修复一个脆弱或破裂的纽带。在违法行为中失去的东西，其实有两个方面，两个大要素。一方面，违法行为威胁到了关系，威胁到了你们共享的身份，（你知道的）你们是谁，（你知道的）如果我们谈论的是后关系。你是谁？你们作为伴侣是谁，你们分享的价值观。另一方面，它确实也威胁到了那种地位和权力的等级制度。所以，（你知道的）违法行为贬低了另一方。它破坏了他们。它剥夺了控制权。
the other party. It undermines them, it removes control. And so from an apology standpoint, apologies is a kind of a response to that loss, are an attempt to recover either one of those pillars. So apologies can help to rebuild the relationship, reestablish the agreement, what the relationship is based on, or they can transmit power and control to the other party. They give the other party the option to forgive. They communicate that degrading you was the wrong thing to do. The apology is often the starting point to the conversation. Now that you've actually admitted that something is wrong, now we can talk about the right way to move forward. And so it's perhaps not surprising that victim groups are not immediately forgiving in the face of an apology because the apology is an opening.
另一方。它破坏了他们，剥夺了控制权。因此，从道歉的角度来看，道歉是对这种损失的一种回应，是恢复这两大支柱之一的尝试。所以道歉可以帮助重建关系，重新确立协议，也就是关系建立的基础，或者它们可以将权力和控制权传递给另一方。它们赋予另一方原谅的选择权。它们传达了贬低你是一件错误的事情。道歉通常是对话的起点。既然你已经承认出了问题，现在我们可以讨论前进的正确方式了。因此，受害者群体在面对道歉时不会立即原谅，这也许并不令人意外，因为道歉是一个开端。
And it's the first step in moving forward towards real reconciliation. You know, one of the things that I think I'm really struck by is an echo I'm hearing in what you're saying and what we heard from the psychologist Charlotte Whitfleet. We talk with her about the challenges of forgiveness and how it's often difficult to forgive and sometimes we look for forgiveness in our hearts and don't find it or we wait until we receive the right apology and often that apology is not forthcoming. And I think what you're saying, Tyler, is the mirror image of that, which is that you might come up with a beautiful apology, the right apology, but maybe the victim
它是迈向真正和解的第一步。你知道，我想我真正感到震惊的事情之一，是我在你的话语中以及我们从心理学家夏洛特·惠特弗利那里听到的话语中听到的回响。我们与她讨论了原谅的挑战，以及为什么原谅往往很困难，有时我们在心中寻找原谅却找不到，或者我们一直等到收到正确的道歉，而往往那个道歉并没有到来。而泰勒，我认为你所说的是它的镜像，那就是你可能会想出一个美丽的道歉，正确的道歉，但也许受害者
is not ready to hear it. And maybe it's actually going to fall on deaf ears, and maybe you're not gonna get the reconciliation that you seek. And I think a common thread that connects these two veins of research is perhaps the idea of both forgiveness and apologies as gifts, gifts that we give one another without an automatic expectation of reciprocation.
还没有准备好听到它。也许它真的会无人理睬，也许你不会得到你所寻求的和解。我认为连接这两条研究脉络的共同线索，也许是将原谅和道歉都视为礼物的想法，这是我们彼此给予的礼物，而不带有自动期望回报的期待。
What do you make of that idea, Tyler? A number of psychologists have really conceptualized apologies as a gift that comes without expectation. And I think that there's something really important in that. Thinking about apologies, not as a linear progression, but really as a offering, as a gesture that is unconditional, is probably good for getting them to have positive effects both on the victim as well as on your relationship. I asked Tyler whether he had ever failed to apologize to someone he cared about. He mentioned his daughter Abigail and how he sometimes loses his temper with her and then fails to apologize.
泰勒，你对这个想法有什么看法？许多心理学家确实将道歉概念化为一种没有期望的礼物。我认为其中有一些非常重要的事情。将道歉不视为线性进展，而是真正视为一种奉献，一种无条件的姿态，这对于让它们对受害者以及对你的关系产生积极影响可能是好的。我问泰勒他是否曾未能向他关心的人道歉。他提到了他的女儿阿比盖尔（Abigail），以及他是如何有时对她发脾气然后又未能道歉的。
I asked him what he would tell Abigail if she were listening right now. Well, this actually sounds like one of our experiments where we get people to reflect on a time they didn't apologize and so I suppose it's a fair question because I subject other people to go through this process which is actually quite difficult. So if I was to offer an apology to my daughter, I'll probably go something like this. Abigail, you know, I realized that what I said and how really how I said it was a bit over the top, I was really frustrated and angry at the time, which was probably not the right state of mind to be in when parenting. And you know, I recognize that the choice that I made to respond in that way is really hurtful to you.
我问他，如果阿比盖尔现在正在收听，他会对她说什么。嗯，这实际上听起来像是我们的实验之一，我们让人们反思他们没有道歉的时候，所以我想这是一个公平的问题，因为我让其他人经历这个过程，这其实相当困难。所以如果要向我的女儿道歉，我可能会这样说。阿比盖尔，（你知道的）我意识到我所说的话以及我说话的方式确实有点过分了，我当时真的很沮丧和生气，这可能不是育儿时应该处于的正确心态。你知道的，我承认我选择以那种方式回应确实对你造成了伤害。
It probably doesn't do great things for our relationship and I promise to do my best to be better. Even in the future I do fly off the handle. Feel free to give me the signal that I have done such. I'm sure your mother will help as well. And it's something that I'm committed to improving, because I know that it's what's best for our relationship. Tyler Okimodo is a psychologist at the University of Queensland in Australia. Tyler, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. If you have follow-up questions about apologies that you'd be willing to share with the Hidden
它对我们的关系可能没有太大益处，我承诺会尽力做得更好。即使在未来我确实发脾气了。请随时给我一个信号，表明我已经这样做了。我确信你母亲也会帮忙的。这是我致力于改进的事情，因为我知道这对我们的关系最好。泰勒·奥基莫托（Tyler Okimoto）是澳大利亚昆士兰大学的心理学家。泰勒，非常感谢你今天加入Hidden Brain。谢谢你邀请我。如果你有关于道歉的后续问题愿意与Hidden
Brain audience, please record a voicemail on your phone and send it to ideas at hiddenbrain.org. 60 seconds is plenty. That email address is ideas at hiddenbrain.org and use the subject line, Apologies. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Christian Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Bounds, Andrew Chadwick
Brain观众分享，请在你的手机上录制一条语音留言，并发送至 ideas at hiddenbrain.org。60秒就足够了。那个电子邮件地址是 ideas at hiddenbrain.org，并使用主题行：道歉（Apologies）。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯蒂安·王（Christian Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·鲍恩斯（Autumn Bounds）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）
and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you have found the episodes in our Healing 2.0 series to be moving or useful, please share them with one or more people in your life. If they don't know how to access Hidden Brain, either on podcast players or their local public radio station, please show them how to do so. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。如果你发现我们“疗愈2.0”（Healing 2.0系列中的单集令人感动或有用，请与你生活中的一个人或多个人分享。如果他们不知道如何在播客播放器或当地公共广播电台访问Hidden Brain，请向他们展示如何操作。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。再见。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。